vision challenge and visual recognition
and how we can try to expand the way we
teach these systems using unlabeled
video so just to make sure the stage is
clear in terms of the eventual goal for
these systems I'm talking about we want
to have systems that can understand
images in the deepest sense possible so
be able to take a scene like this and
understand its object categories its
object instances the activities
happening or that might happen the
attributes and so on if this is a
challenge and a challenge tackled by
many many researchers in the field and
one way to look at what we're trying to
do is to look at the benchmark datasets
that really feed the algorithms to learn
how to do these different mechanism
tasks and so I'm showing a sampling of
them here one that's driven a great deal
of progress for the community includes
the image net data set where given
million exemplars or more we can train
recognition systems that can categorize
objects into a thousand different
categories right and as I'm sure many of
you are aware there's been tremendous
progress in the last five years in being
able to do this quite well okay so this
is exciting and it's possible in part
because of such large datasets that have
been manually curated and labeled as
well as the amounts of computation we
can now bring to it as well as successes
very relevant to this workshop in
representation learning so if you take
this view of the challenge as well as
how we're teaching these recognition
systems and well what are we teaching
them so right now the most important way
or the biggest way in which we convey
information to these visual learners
it's through labelled exemplars okay so
if we want to have a system that
understands the difference between dogs
and boats and a thousand other things we
have curated a thousand or more images
for each of those categories to teach
the concept so I will put this forth
that's really a limitation for what
we'll be able to do going moving on from
here
okay so teaching a visual recognition
system in this way is limiting it's
expensive it's literally expensive so
you
the community invest hundreds of
thousands millions of dollars at this
point in gathering these labeled
exemplars but more important than that
it's quite restrictive in scope it's
restricting the way we can teach the
system it's also restricting our
assumptions about what we want these
systems to do at test time and that
restriction is very evident if we we
think about this status quo which again
is learning from these label examples
web photos that humans have manually
tagged with their objects these are
really disembodied snapshots right
they're moments in time in which an
object usually central in the view has
been photographed and then labeled this
is restrictive if we then contrast this
right away with how visual learning
takes place in nature where we're not
learning from disembodied flashcards
about objects instead we're learning in
very loosely supervised and even
unsupervised ways by specifically acting
and interacting with the environment
okay so in other words visual learning
takes place in an embodied way takes
place in the context of how an agent is
acting and moving in the world and this
is quite different right now in visual
recognition from how our best systems
learn so a big picture goal in my group
right now is to help make progress in
shifting from this disembodied visual
learning towards a more embodied visual
learning progress process and what would
this consist of well it would mean being
able to take account of continuous
observations long-running observations
probably video it would also mean being
able to take into account multi-sensory
input not just the visual stream but
others as well and I believe that if we
do this we'll have a lot of opportunity
presented for what's possible for one
this will be you know we have the
argument of less expensive learning
which is attractive moving from strongly
supervised to unsupervised learning but
also again more importantly this ability
to learn in a way that's unrestricted in
its scope so if I have agents that can
learn by experimenting and experiencing
things in the world in a sense this is
free and limitless right in terms of how
much can be learned
with what amount of data okay so that's
the big picture golden to think about
how to bring about embodied forms of
visual learning for the sake of
recognition many ways we can go about
doing this
what I'll share with you our steps we're
taking to ground these visual
observations specifically in ego motion
so there's three points I want to show
you one will be learning a
representation that's tied to an agent's
ego motion and I'll build on that and
briefly discuss how we can extend this
to agents that are simply watching video
and don't have specific knowledge of
their own ego motion and then finally
we'll kind of look the other way and
instead of only learning to do better
things conscious of motion and
embodiment we'll look at how to use what
we've learned about the right way to
move in order to succeed online on a
recognition task in other words to know
how to move around at test time or to
know where to look given all the places
we could look let's look then at
learning representations tied to ego
motion and here I will motivate with a
classic experiment from cognitive
science that some of you may have seen
and others not let me tell you in a
nutshell what this experiment was about
this Khitan carousel experiment so these
scientists are studying kittens and
their visual development from birth the
kittens are in the dark from birth
except for about an hour at a time per
day where they're on this contraption
that you see sketched here this carousel
is built in such a way that you can put
two animals at a time one of those
kittens will be the active kitten and
this kitten has control of its own
motion in the confines of this carousel
the other kitten is a passive kitten who
by construction you know look notice his
paws aren't touching the ground here
we'll be seeing what the active kitten
sees but is not having the same control
over where it goes
so what happens in this experiment in
terms of their visual development
well the active kittens development
proceeds normally where as passive
kittens does not and so there's a
contrast here not in terms of what
they've experienced of what they've seen
but how they've experienced what they've
seen and what does it show just for us
well it says that it wasn't just about
the the pixels that came in for the sake
of learning but it was about the motor
experience while having those pixels
come in the active kitten presumably
here in this well in this experiment is
benefiting from choosing its own motion
in the world being conscious of that
motion as he takes the the different
steps so in a very loose sense we're not
kind of scientist but we're trying to
look at this as inspiration for what we
might try to achieve in the
computational models that are learning
in an embodied way okay so in other
words how do we get that self Jenner in
motion and that visual feedback and
awareness into a modern recognition
system okay so the idea is then to link
and convey to a learning algorithm this
connection between how I move and what I
see okay so we'd like to bestow this
information or force really the vision
system to learn this connection in order
to do this we want to look at so-called
egocentric visual observations so
egocentric self-centered this can be
done with a wearable camera on a human
so Google glass could be this egocentric
platform could also be on a vehicle so
as we'll see in some results in a moment
it could be a camera perched on an
autonomous vehicle or even a handheld
camera that has motion with the self so
we're gonna take unlabeled video coming
from such egocentric points of view and
along with it
sensor data external to the visual
measurements that tell you about the ego
mushrooms so this could be accelerometer
data GPS coordinates and so on this is
what we're going to allow the learning
system to build up a representation from
in concert or prior to tackling a
specific categorization challenge
recognizing objects or scenes and images
so then how are we going to teach or
require the system to pick up on this
connection we cast this in terms of a
view prediction task okay so it's a view
prediction cap task that's conditioned
on ego motion where an agent needs to
predict before making a certain ego
motion what the world will look like
after it makes that motion that's what
we'll require now let me have you kind
of put your just to kind of live through
this experience what we're gonna ask the
system to learn let's do it ourselves
all right let's do a view predictions
ask ourselves where we're sitting in
this vehicle looking out and suppose
this is the view that you encounter now
if you're aware of this link between how
I move what I see then when we suppose
some hypothetical 3d Eagle motion of the
vehicle that you're sitting in you could
now stri to imagine what the new view
will look like certainly not expecting
us to paint the pixels in a perfect way
from this view to this imagined view but
nonetheless there is background and
foundational vision cues that would
allow us to have a guess of this new
view let me show you what the view
happens to be in this particular case
and now let's think about okay if I have
a system that knows how to predict given
this image given that rotation what the
new view is what is it forced to pick up
on for one it's forced to know something
about semantics because because suppose
you know seeing these lights the
intersection suggests there is a street
intersection below even though it's not
observed yet it's also forced to pick up
on things about geometry so there's a
tower in the background a tree in the
foreground with the rotation large
enough this will include the background
Tower
okay so queues about depth Asians and so
on and finally there's cues about
grouping so symmetry cues for example
might allow you to extrapolate and
predict the other face of the building
that you haven't observed this again
motivating for what what in insisting
that and the system learn how to do ego
motion condition
prediction what properties it will also
be required to succeed at learning along
the way so then how do we how do we cast
this in terms of you know what do we
actually want to learn for the
representation or the feature mapping
function so we're gonna cast this in
terms of equal variant feature learning
which is a generalization of invariant
feature learning so specifically if I
have an invariant representation suppose
I have images X and some transformations
G and I'm learning a feature mapping Z
then an invariant feature mapping would
discard those transformations right so
maybe G is a shift and I've learned a
function Z where even after you shift
the image X it looks the same in my
mapped space and we're very familiar and
have very good ways in which not just to
hand code invariant features but also
learn them including from video now what
we'll use to tackle this ego motion tied
representation is instead a
generalization of invariants called
equal variance where we won't get
discard those transformations but we
will organize their effects okay so now
the feature mapping function Z still
will be learned but also will be some
simple mappings one for every go motion
G that organizes in a simple way here a
linear equivalent mapping the different
ego motions that can be experienced such
that after you know if I have my image
before and then my image after say that
car's rotation then I would like the
features I get back not to be identical
but to be relatable by some simple
transformation so the goal then will be
to learn Z and learn those mappings M
let me show you one slide about how we
implement this idea and we're
implementing with deep convolutional
neural networks coming in we're going to
have video with this ego motion motor
signal which again is externally sensed
from other sensors than the video but
it's unlabeled and by unlabeled I mean
no human has touched it to say what the
semantic objects are and we'll be
learning this function I'm Alaska sides
called Z where pairs of frames that are
related by the same Eagle motion are
related by the same feature
transformation in this learn space in a
2d cartoon of this this means that if I
had some original frame from the video
and I know about ego motions like moving
forward turning right turning left then
those motions will be organized with
simple transformations from the original
view in this learn feature space and
maybe they layout like stone furthermore
we'll have learned this for all the
video that we've trained with and any
new individual snapshot can be mapped
into this space and now the power we
have is that this understanding is there
we've insisted that we understand
connection between how I move what I see
so if the algorithm imagines what it's
like to move forward from this image we
have a representation for that or
similarly turning left turning right and
so on
so the implementation of this take the
unlabeled video together with its 3d
Eagle motions depicted here with the red
arrows and come back with this equal
variant feature space so what we need to
learn the parameters of this function as
well as these matrices and one for every
go motion G and in the unsupervised
training then we'll take pairs of these
frames and again if there's similar in
Eagle motion they need to have similar
they need to be related by the same
mapping em so we implement this with a
pair of Siamese embedding so these are
identical stacks of convolutional neural
network that will pass either frame from
the pair through and then for the Eagle
motion G relating these two views we
have an additional network here that
needs to take care of that
transformation after which these two
will be the same shown here is just
enormous the loss but actually this is a
contrastive loss yes question okay so
there would be data dependent I'm
showing three in this cartoon when we
implement it with the data set here it
was a it was about six and we discovered
these Eagle motions by clustering the
sensor readings that came to us into
some discrete set of big emotions
we've also played with using continuous
motions and not having to do this
discretization but so far we're not
getting better results by doing that
that's right
yeah one for each ego motion yep yes the
Buchanon is a projection so it's
basically just a function of the depth
and also the the viewpoint change so why
are not it
Yeah right right so we're not we're not
measuring the depth we're measuring just
the single 2d images you can also think
you could you could try to explicitly
extract even the Eagle motion from the
visual signal itself what we're what
we're insisting on here is the ability
to do the 2d view prediction condition
on the Eagle motion but you could think
of the same the same framework taking
depth either as part of your input as or
even part of the output that you're
trying it for and the same motivation
would hold for for doing this yeah okay
so this is then allowing us to get back
these learned representation that's
Eagle motion sensitive we've played with
it in different ways including if we'd
like to jointly train recognition models
you could try to learn parameters not
just for the the mapping but also some
classifiers at the same time or in the
results I'll show you next we can do
this purely on supervised learning and
then do some simple classification in
the space that we've learned so let me
show you one kind of key result of
applying this idea where we took
unlabeled video from the kitty dataset
this is a video captured on a vehicle
where the car is driving around
different different locations in a city
okay so these are experts that we're
training from again they're unlabeled to
our algorithm it's just video and then
the recognition tasks that we're trying
to address here is scene classification
this is a challenge with about 400
different scene categories at test time
you're given one of these images and you
need to say is it a freeway is it a
cathedral is that a library etc so these
aren't necessarily aligned in category
in fact they're largely not however what
we'd like to see is can we build up in
the representation those foundational
vision cues about semantics context
geometry such that we can succeed better
on this task particularly when we have
very few labeled examples for the target
tasks
and in one in one result as I'm showing
here we're looking at the accuracy so
higher is better versus pulling out
features from different layers of these
networks the best layer among any of
them for a given method is summarized
here and the baselines I'm showing you
here include using us the same
architecture but with random weights in
it using a a well a well studied form of
invariant feature learning or using a
concurrently proposed technique that
also makes use of ego motion and our
results are improving on all of these
baselines showing the value you know of
going beyond invariant feature learning
in towards equal variance
and by capitalizing on ego motion so
moving from here on an ongoing work
we're thinking about not just predicting
the the relationship between pairs of
these use but also predicting the entire
3d object shape all right so we're
tasking now our systems with learning
given one view from an unknown viewing
angle can the system reconstruct the
entire view grid so an image based
representation of the 3d shape yes you
were just saying before if you just
consider the pairs of views that where
one could be seen as a magnification of
the other how is it doing in terms of
just fine structure so it would be sort
of a subset of
so let me see if I understand the
question you're saying what if we learn
only from scaling effect moving forward
is primarily a magnification and if you
look at for example the flu summation of
fine structure or if it is sort of doing
some way of judging just the error on
that one aspect I see right so we have
not evaluated it learning from you know
one Eagle motion at a time so I don't
know
you know how it differs if we look only
at scaling versus you know arbitrary you
go motion and as far as the fine grain
structure how much and one thing to keep
in mind is where we're doing this view
prediction in the feature space rather
than in the pixel space so we don't
produce images from this although we
have played a bit with you know mapping
back from the embedding space what would
be the nearest image does it look like
the right thing and that looks okay how
finer other structures depends on which
version of this we're implementing we
started doing it with some rather tiny
images for efficiency so it's a 32 by 32
this point the images are 227 by 227 so
when you retrieve an image it can it can
look pretty clear question
okay so we're looking out and this is
all I'll say about it but just trying to
enhancer or more difficult the learning
challenge and still look at this in
terms of feature learning in an
unsupervised way so an agent that knows
how things look as it turns its head or
locks all around them
can then be given a new single view of
an object and although already have had
past hypotheses about what it looks if
it were to move around so I've talked
about ego motion tight representations
let me briefly address how we can relax
the need to have ego motions sensory
data okay so what if I don't have the
the the egocentric video together with
motion sense but I just have that you go
fit the video okay I just have passively
watched video this is an attractive case
also to deal with because of the amount
of unlabeled video that exists that may
not have these external sensor readings
and in looking at how to deal with this
more general form really of the training
process we look as a starting point at
Sloat what's called slow feature
analysis so a form of invariant feature
learning where in the case of learning
from video we say okay the the semantic
signal the high-level information is
only going to change slowly over time
most of the time and whereas the pixels
that will change with some high high
frequency so in existing work with slow
feature analysis or invariant feature or
learning one can look at adjacent video
frames or nearby video frames and using
this assumption of temporal coherence
say that okay in my embedding space
things shouldn't change too much so that
frame T thinks should be pretty similar
at frame T plus one and get a feature
representation that maintains that
coherence what we proposed is to expand
so feature analysis to slow and steady
feature analysis by imposing a
higher-order notion of temporal
coherence so instead of looking at
adjacent frames we can look at
neighborhoods of frame for example if we
look at Triplets of frames we can say
not only should the change be slow but
the change
the the changes themselves that not only
from A to B should things change Sully
but the change from A to B should be
like the change from B to C and so you
can see how that would allow us to
express to the learning algorithm upon
Triplets of frames how things should
work out in the learn feature spaces E
and we can make an argument of how doing
so then we'll maintain this notion of
feature equal variance but in this case
you'll notice learning not with that
motor signal learning just with the raw
video yeah so how is this implemented
yeah so this is implemented with a
Siamese triplet embedding so you have
triple of stacks now and then the loss
is basically oh yeah sorry
so like the network I briefly showed
before where there was these two stacks
well you know frame XT and XT plus one
came in those stacks had the same
parameters and the loss at the end in
that case was based on the you know how
different is the mapping for the first
frame and then the second one after that
linear map M that was so that's what we
tried to minimize in this case though
it's not depicted here things are quite
similar only now instead of two stacks
you have three because you have a B and
C coming in and you'd like this to be
the thing that is minimized
and you're agnostic about like whether
you using your left or some other injury
well I mean our only implementation of
it has been in a deep network
conditional Network but the principle of
of higher order temporal coherence is
more general but this is how we've
implemented it right so the the losses
contrastive loss rather than the
occluding in norman on the difference
which in the contrastive loss you're
saying I would like the the correct
wants to be closed and that they have
negative pairs right that say that they
should be closer than some negative
pairs it's not depict in my slides what
we could talk about it offline if it's
adventurous the negative pers random
pairs these are easy negative example ah
right so right there they're random as
in from the wrong eagle motion yeah so
one can do things like a flavor of hard
negative mining where you try to focus
on what are the most useful negatives to
have in there in this implementation
they were they were random complete if
you wanted to use fewer if you wanted to
train more quickly you could try to zero
on the the most useful negatives here it
seems that you're going from assuming
that these locally constants believe in
error what you should come in by
stopping here it could assume that it's
locally kinetic and look at more like
you know water Blitzen yeah we should as
to why you should wait why stop here we
do have some intuition I do think we'll
get diminishing returns as we go higher
in fact we if we want even higher orders
the reason is at what point does this
steadiness slowness persist in temporal
distance right so eventually things do
change and video and not everything you
know so locally we can expect these kind
of slow and steady changes but as you
look further out and when does a video
think of how quickly it might change
these assumptions might start to break
and you're learning you know more poorly
in an unsupervised way
you might yeah so so it hasn't been
tried empirically so I can't say but
this was our reasoning at least for
stopping at this point there's also the
complexity we work we are kind of you
know it could be overcome but in terms
of having so many stacks in memory and
the implementation we need to get
smarter
once you have not just triplets but
quadruplets or so on all right so this
allows us to be true couch potatoes
learned from unlabeled video in a in a
more passive way but still achieve equal
variant future maths that are useful for
recognition so the result I wanted to
highlight here looks at using this
unlabeled video as a form of pre
training so when the room is already
familiar with what it means to pre train
a representation so it's about a third
it's my best guess let me try to depict
briefly what this looks like so this has
been a really big success and very
practical tool that we're capitalizing
in and on individual recognition and the
idea is you know maybe I have a new task
for which I haven't spent five hundred
thousand dollars to get labeled examples
but I have a few labels for it well
that's some the the nice thing is that
empirically people show that if I have a
related enough task for example if my
new task is related enough to imagenet
for which there are 14 million labeled
examples then I could take a network
train it for the original task for which
we do have many labels learn it's
classifiers and then treat that as a
starting point to learn my new test for
which labels are too few so in other
words copy over those weights in the
network and fine-tune from there to get
the classifier that supports your actual
task this is pre-training you kind of
pre train the representation for another
task it's not the same task but with the
expectation it's related enough and
people have been somewhat surprised at
what counts is related enough then it
can help you succeed at your new task
better than if you just tried to train
from scratch from
where you would not succeed okay so
that's what can be done in a supervised
way so what we're now testing is okay
what if our pre training is watching
this video watching the only level video
not labeled by a person virtually free
and let that be the thing that prepares
the representation that we then fine
tune with the labeled data so this is
attractive for the ease and supervision
one result that I'll highlight here
that's most encouraging as far as how
far this could take us looks like this
so what we'd really like to see happen
is to push past the limits of what can
be done with this heavily supervised
mode of learning and can unlabeled video
help us do it so in this chart we'll
look at the accuracy for an action
recognition task so the system is given
an image like the bottom left from this
Pascal data set they need the system has
to say what action category is taking
place and if we learn just from those
images which are there's very few that
are labeled then we're down here in
accuracy if we allow our system to pre
trained with a video data set of YouTube
data which has minor to not overlap in
actual labels with this data then things
get much better right so this is the
power of the slow and steady future
analysis and the important thing is that
if instead I take that supervised pre
training approach that I depicted on the
previous slide where there's a related
task here it consists of a hundred way
object categorization from the stefarr
data set if I take that data and keep
augmenting my pre training for a
supervised baseline even once I exhaust
all of the fifty thousand images in this
collection the pre trained
representation ends up being a bit
inferior to the free unsupervised pre
training process with video but on
YouTube
waving a tendency for so did you try
alright right so so we we used the max
of this and I don't remember offhand how
many videos how many frames it's gonna
it's gonna be more than 50,000 frames
but yeah so it's a good question you
know what are the charts look like at
what point do you saturate from the
video because we say oh well though
unlivable video is free and it's ample
we'd liked you you know a good
experiment is to see at which point do
those curves flatten with more unlabeled
video right at which point is there no
new signal from just watching more of
the same things I want to the
philosophical point right there is the
kitten example that you have made you
his video I mean are you learning from
video more because it is so much better
or is it a better fundamentally better
way mm-hmm right so you're saying
equalize equalize not just the amount of
supervision but the amount of data yeah
yeah so the Khitan hypothesis is tested
once we look at I'd say the kid my
father this test it even had the
left-hand side of this curve in that for
the same amount of supervision or the
same the same supervision supervised
visual experience for all systems is
this so it's equal we get benefit out of
paying attention to how ego motion
connects right yeah and so you know
where we are right now this is a bit
more like a passive kitten because he's
watching video rather than moving around
so so there's that difference yes
so in the remainder I want to highlight
then shifting gears from learning in an
embodied way towards acting an embodied
way for recognition and here it's
important to note that as I mentioned at
the onset you know our benchmark
challenges are somewhat limited in our
scope and that means that at test time
they're passive and disembodied to means
we're where we have these systems that
can do very well at web photo labeling
so you give us an image of an object and
the system must say what it is or given
an image of a scene we say what it is
but if we're active if we have systems
that understand how their motion relates
to what they see let's let the system
move around and make its recognition
decisions that way this is the classic
problem of active recognition okay which
has history and early years of computer
vision but mostly absent from mainstream
modern visual recognition today we'd
like systems that can operate on a
mobile robot of any kind or even a robot
that can manipulate an object so don't
stop at one view don't be passive that
decision time either but be active so
we've been exploring this and I'm not
going to go into a lot of detail I just
want to most motivate the task a hint of
what we've done and show you a result
but this is the kind of imagery one
deals with if one doesn't take web
photos as the input okay so these are
all snapshots that we captured from a
human worn camera and what I'd like you
to see in these is the difficulty in
terms of motion blur that's their poor
composition right these are just photos
that are passively gathered from an
egocentric camera so this looks hard and
bad in terms of performing recognition
on such data it's particularly when you
contrast' it with what the massive
supervised datasets look like that the
way objects we're used to seeing them on
the other hand the whole point of active
recognition is now you have this
opportunity to change your observation
okay so I might get a view like this but
the agent can be intelligent about how
to change its view through its own
motion so you know in this cartoon if
it's looking at this object and can't
tell if it's a mug or a bowl or a pan
there's a way to find out and that is
move in the right way and disambiguate
the object category so when you build
such an active recognition system you
need several components three in fact so
one you need perception again you have
some representation you look at the
scene and you have some initial set of
posteriors over what you're seeing
you also need now a means to do action
selection so given what we've seen what
should how should I move next and then
we also need to iterate on this we'll
get some new observation and a third
component required is to do evidence
fusion of everything that's seen so far
so we looked at the literature in active
recognition over the years you'll see
that each of these three modules are
tackled independently and methods are
really dedicated towards doing any one
in isolation where now we have the
opportunity to think about learning all
these things jointly so we've been
exploring so called end and learning of
a active policy to perform visual
recognition you learn the policy for how
to select the action at the same time
you learn the representation for the
perception or for how to fuse the
evidence and with it we can in inject
the notion of look-ahead as I talked
about at the beginning of the talk so
how do you evaluate it I'll show you
results from three tasks so evaluation
is less convenient in the active
recognition setting because things
dynamically change as a function of your
motions but we can use things like 360
data
so here the agent is in a 3d environment
we have a 360 panorama from all viewing
angles and we'll choose which glimpses
to take within that viewing sphere over
time and the second task we have a robot
with manipulating an object and we can
choose how should the robot move its
hand to see the object better and we're
also looking at some recent data sets
like model net which have artificial
objects rendered from arbitrary
viewpoints so Scene Recognition object
recognition and object recognition and
different active settings and when we
look at results in terms of how many
glimpses do you require
emotions do you take in the environment
versus how accurate the system can do
how accurate the system is that test
time what you'd like to see is a curve
that goes up sharply because it would
mean with a little bit of motion and
effort things become very clear to the
system and this is where we're at our
results here in dotted red and very
various baselines passive and previous
attempts for active recognition are
shown I'll show you a qualitative
example of an active scene recognition
system so think of this agent dropped
into a 360 panorama the 360 panorama
here consists of these little chips of
different viewing angles just flattened
onto the screen and if we drop it in
maybe initially the first view is shown
in this pink square it looks like this
and at this point the system thinks it's
a restaurant or a train or a shop it's
actually wrong it's a plaza courtyard
but within the next action action space
considered this yellow grid it will
choose its next glimpse and at this
point updating its belief to say well
given all these people tightly clustered
together maybe it's a theater restaurant
or a courtyard and then one more
actively chosen glimpse it decides to
swing its camera up right and see the
side of this building and at this point
succeed in finding it as a positive
courtyard
and similar things we can show with the
robot manipulating an object so and once
you start working with dynamic objects
in unlabeled video and doing active
recognition of objects moving over time
it's also important to pull out which
regions belong to any object and so I'm
just showing some results here from our
approach in recent work where we can
perform foreground segmentation in video
so making use both of the appearance as
well as the motion of the object to come
out with foreground masks that you see
here this do we're getting these results
using a a2 stream network that looks at
both again they're both the appearance
in the optical flow
okay so then the final thing I'll share
is a result that looks not just at
deciding where to look for this a sub
think of recognizing the object but in
this case deciding where to look to help
you view a video so if you capture a
video with a 360 camera you're very
happy about the fact that you didn't
have to do work at capture time to
decide where to direct the camera
furthermore the viewer of the eventual
video has a lot of power in their hands
to decide where to look right none of
this has been chosen this is also kind
of a burden right so if you've tried to
watch 360 video you know that you know
either you're wearing your headset and
doing a lot of physical motion to decide
where to look or as this slide shows
clicking around on the video to swing
the camera to where the interesting
content might be so let's take the ideas
as I just described of learning policies
about where to look over time and take
it to this problem we're given a 360
video we'd like to direct a virtual
camera ok so decide where to point that
camera over time and even how to change
its field of view this is a challenge
that we've recently started working on
and defining in terms of 360 video in
and normal field of video out and we
learned this from unlabeled video in the
interest of time I'll jump to the result
basically we can learn what human taken
videos look like just by watching
YouTube and so you give us a 360 video
like this one here's just flattened into
the plane and we'll select as shown in
the red outline a trajectory of
viewpoints or glimpses over time that
make human looking human taken video
that looks as if it were human taken so
in this particular case in the aquarium
it's chosen to look at this diver and
then track it and zoom in and out
accordingly just one of its hypotheses
that it would put forward as a way to
watch this
unlabeled 360 video ok so I've talked
about embodied visual learning
moving from disembodied photo labeling
towards context of action and motion for
the sake of training visual recognition
systems and the main ideas I showed
where learning features tidy commotion
and
policies that use that look-ahead
ability to move around intelligently and
the work that I showed you was done with
the the three students that you see here
that I stopped and happy to take any
further questions or comments that's
what's happening in the in the couch
potato who learns from the the
higher-order temporal coherence because
the the ego motion is not explicit right
I think that is possible it's not
something we've attempted though and you
know furthermore we could one could
solve one doesn't need the external
sensor reading to solve for the ego
motion we could try to explicitly show
the algorithm how to do that just from
the views themselves the motivation of
using the external sensor is is that
idea of embodiment and having an outside
read of how things are changing than the
pixels yeah yes Maddie for the ego
motion defenders to correctly your G's
are just local actions
I just wanted to if thinking about it I
don't know if this makes sense or
thinking more broadly I mean these G's
really I mean there are also there's
some structure over them so they figure
if I make two small steps it's like one
misstep or a picture and right and then
let right state though you can get the
same point as wondering if you do or if
it makes sense to impose an errand you
compare
composable possibility scripture the
metric invisibility of gigi's composed
in sequence of genes that get me to
simply those dams right right that's
right we've thought a little bit about
this so the set of G's you know they are
composable and so it's some so if we
wanted the minimal set of G's we could
take those that you know express all the
ego motions through composition and we
thought about this in terms of you know
how big one if we do discretize the
space you know how big should it be how
many should there be and we looked we've
looked a little bit at preserving equal
variance for those motions which are in
our set G versus those that are
compositions of G and empirically as you
might expect
you know we best preserve equal variance
for those that we directly are
representing but we still maintain a
covariance a shade work you know a shade
more poorly for those that are
compositions of those G's yeah but it
might be it could be an interesting
problem to think about the vocabulary of
ego motions explicitly in terms of the
composition or perhaps learning the
vocabulary of ego motions that belong in
this in this learning process itself
yes sound good
[Applause]